all right let's get into this week's
mailbag email bag as many of you know
the email bag ranges from the extremely
low brow ignorant and hateful to really
interesting ideas suggestions
questions all sorts of different things
info davidpakman.com is the place to
send your emails remember we get 500
emails a day and we go over about eight
a week so i just want everybody to you
know i get emails and then i get emails
about why haven't you read my email yet
uh and sometimes i get the second one
within hours of the first one it's like
hey guys i do sleep sometimes you know
okay let's get to the emails first one
it's from a guy who's been writing in
for a while his name is gary b
and he said did you get your booster yet
dumbass and in fact i did i i mentioned
last week that i was going this is an
anti-vaxx nut who's been emailing for a
long time
i think he writes in sometimes about
motor oil in vaccines if i recall
correctly i got my booster on
thursday
i got it at 4 30
went to bed around 11 had a little bit
of arm pain
and then the next morning woke up at 7
30
a little bit feverish although i didn't
have a fever headache headache like
behind the eyes
and just achy took a tylenol with
breakfast and that helped a lot worked
the regular day slept a lot friday night
and then was basically better on
saturday
so i am now triple vaxxed and i'm
feeling boosted and all of these
different things but yes gary thank you
for asking i did indeed
get my booster some call it a third dose
they're probably coming for everybody is
what it seems to be given again we've
got another rise in cases
and uh especially what we know about the
decreased efficacy particularly of the
jnj vaccine but in general um i by the
way i got two moderna shots as my
initial uh regimen and then i got a
modern booster as well okay second email
from jake jake says
john bolton predicted trump won't run
for president again in 2024 because he
fears being known as a loser if it
doesn't work out this is what michael
cohen keeps saying trump will not run
because he can't handle the potential
humiliation these guys close to trump
seem to be sure of this jonathan yeah
i've spoken to michael cohen about this
directly and i think that he's
completely
he's making a completely plausible case
i think the question is we don't yet
know whether trump is likely to lose in
2024. as i've said before if republicans
do well in 22 and biden doesn't do well
in his uh third year of his presidency
second and third
and into the election cycle
and in particular if biden doesn't even
run for re-election
i think that it looks okay for trump i
think a trump versus biden rematch is
good for trump
i think if biden doesn't run in kamala
harris as the democratic nominee i think
that's good for trump so i agree with
what michael cohen says and said to me
when i was on his show i agree i haven't
seen this john bolton thing but i i'm
sure it's
it might be right um
i think if trump knows he will lose he
won't do it because he doesn't want to
suffer a humiliation
i just don't know that it's clear trump
will lose yet and so we're going to be
watching that it's a question we all
care about here's a longer voicemail but
it's a very very interesting one this
one is from mark and mark wanted to
weigh in on why people on the right call
me gay marx says david you asked why
people on the right assume you're gay i
am a gay man who is politically active
and i have some ideas based in personal
experience with right wingers first most
of us who are actually gay realize
you're straight and you're an ally
i'm very glad for all the straight
allies we have i've never picked up on a
gay vibe from you my gaydar does not
even register as much as a blip when i
watch your youtube videos listen to mark
however
for a lot of people on the right
particularly the far right there is just
nothing worse than being gay hence gay
becomes the perfect epithet
if they don't like your politics then
that means you're gay if they don't like
your position on social issues then that
means you're gay if they don't like you
period that must be because you're gay
and they're straight no self-respecting
right-winger would tolerate a gay person
in their midst except possibly those who
suddenly decided they were quote cured
and we all know how long gay cures
last
very interesting email from mark
um
so there it is it's sort of like a
presented without comment
very interesting to hear from mark on
that
next email is from jessica
jessica says hi mr pacman i've walked
watched your show for a while now and
i've heard you say you're a progressive
but not a democrat would you say you're
independent then just wondering since if
someone said they were progressive i'd
think they meant a progressive
democratic
love your videos thanks so jessica with
total peace and love you may have a few
terms confused progressive is a
political ideology
sort of like socialist someone says
they're a socialist
they might be
a member of the democratic party or not
they might be a member of the socialist
party to the extent that sometimes it
exists and sometimes does not but
socialist can be an ideology
uh maybe that's a bad example since
there is a socialist party listen
progressive can be
a member of the democratic party or not
um i've never been a member of the
democratic party i am an independent but
i tend to vote for democrats when that
makes sense in uh partisan elections
all right i hope i've cleared it up
geez
john says hey david love your channel
what do you think of the dem what do you
think the democrats are going to do in
2024
joe biden will be just shy of 82 at the
time of the election i suspect that will
be a major issue for many voters do you
think he will be renominated or step
aside and support kamala harris i like
kamala but i think she's about as
charismatic as al gore have the
democrats painted themselves into a loss
in 2024 john from indiana listen john
it's so early that we don't have
definitive answers to these questions
that being said
i have already stated i have serious
concerns i think 80 plus year old joe
biden
after being hammered on by republicans
rightly or wrongly for four years
against trump
i don't think it looks good for joe
biden
if joe biden steps aside
and the nomination is
given to kamala harris or if she wins it
in a contest
and then it's trump versus kamala
i don't think it's very good desantis
versus kamala i don't think it's very
good for uh democrats so i i am very
worried about that exact scenario
and uh painted themselves into a loss is
starting to editorialize in a way that i
don't i don't know that i'm ready to do
yet
but let's just say
my policy tends to be
i talk about the next election which
right now is 2022.
my concerns are so high for 2024 that i
have found myself wandering into talking
about it more than i typically would and
john from indiana brings up
exactly some of the concerns that i have
next the oh we've got some bonus ones
these are from facebook
these are these are tough okay these are
tough someone wrote to me
and said you need to do more research
doctors and scientists are speaking out
against this vaccine that was all one
sentence
going on to say you're just following
the lies like a good little sheep a ton
you know there's this idea there's this
general understanding
that facebook is particularly a cesspool
of anti-vaxx non-thinking
uh sometimes under-educated
rants and raves that are barely
intelligible
anecdotally we're experiencing that
we're experiencing that and i would say
close to half of the messages we get on
our facebook page result in the person
just being banned because they're either
hurling insults or otherwise harassing
people okay another a facebook special
for you today
i'm going to read this as written
where do you get your information from
bud we still have our constitutional
right of freedom of choice
i don't know what in particular this
refers to
my instinct is
that it's somehow
vaccination related as well
next one
you were a total and complete piece of s
pushing lies and conflicting truth
research nuremberg journalists held
accountable
and then f yourself
with a heated curling iron
you effing worthless sack of s
you will notice
period exclamation point which is an
interesting grammatical curiosity
as well as random capitalization of
words like complete
journalists the f word yourself sack is
capitalized reminiscent of donald trump
it's actually very interesting how a lot
of trumpian lunatics
have picked up on this random
capitalization of nouns and other words
in the middle of sentences so there's
that and then lastly
coming perfectly timed on the heels of
what some call a booster and some call a
third dose
you are so lost you must have a five you
must have five g vacs sickened because
you can't be that stupid and here we
have
one two three four different places
where there's just extra spaces between
words
random capitalization
sentence fragments run on sentence
missing apostrophe and can't
um it it would actually be
so if i said to you i have a sentence
this long
and it has close to double digits of
spelling and grammatical errors you
would say sir that can't be
but it is
but it is it is hard to believe
um we are going to be off next week
thursday and friday we will have a
truncated schedule because of the
um thanksgiving holiday here in the
united states of course many in our
audience don't celebrate thanksgiving
they're not in the united states we will
have a monday tuesday wednesday show and
we will be off thursday friday just
don't want people to be worried or think
the show got pulled off the air
that's next week we still have a
fantastic bonus show for you today you
can sign up at joinpakman.com and get
access to the bonus show it's an extra
program every day
just for you
who say i am going to support this
program financially you can use the
coupon code better21 to get a discount i
look forward to seeing you there
or we will be back monday with brand new
programming just for you